potatoes in my [ __ ] chili
hello i'm russell crowe i have a new
movie
it's called unhinged in that movie
my character is
[Music]
an [ __ ] given my expertise
in the subject of [ __ ] this is the
subreddit
am i the [ __ ] am i the [ __ ] for
storming out of a dinner
when i found they put potatoes
in the chili okay
i am a chili enthusiast i take chili
very seriously because it is a serious
matter
i of course adore traditional texas
chili which has no beans
but it may surprise you to learn i also
tolerate
and am a fan of chili with beans
and i am even a fan of vegetarian chili
these subsets of chili have been around
for so long
that i consider them a valid version
of chili however there are things
that don't go in chile you wouldn't put
ketchup on salmon for instance
or cauliflower in a steak
so when they put my bowl in front of me
i was astonished to see
that in addition to meat and kidney
beans there were chunks of potatoes
potatoes potatoes in my [ __ ] chili
i said you know what the [ __ ]
they asked me what was up when i said i
thought we were having
chili they said this is chili i told
them that there is no universe
and when chili has potatoes in it never
that doesn't go in chile
they said they wanted to try it out i
said
no no
i couldn't believe i was seeing such a
level of disrespect for chile
i left i was accused of storming out and
i guess
that's about right am i the [ __ ]
yep yep
you are an awesome
anyway this one is am i the [ __ ]
for permanently deleting
my girlfriend's instagram
story goes like this my girlfriend and i
have been dating for five years
i don't have any social media no
facebook instagram
twitter snap etc i'm a private guy
and i like keeping my personal life to
myself
my girlfriend on the other hand
is obsessed with instagram she has over
800 photos posted on instagram and is
constantly scrolling through instagram
every waking moment
she's not working or sleeping i
confronted her a few times about this in
the last few years
and she always tells me she'll cut down
on her instagram use
but she never did recently she was using
my laptop
because her laptop was at the store and
i noticed she forgot to log out from her
email
i did the forgot password thing
reset her password to log in and deleted
the account
she woke up the next morning and started
screaming about how i permanently
deleted her instagram instead of
deactivating it
and that i betrayed her trust
now she won't talk to me because she
says she can't recover
instagram and her profile of 10 years is
lost forever
i think she's being incredibly childish
throwing a tantrum over some random app
well let me think about this as the
chief [ __ ] adjudicator
basically what you've done is equivalent
to you
breaking into this woman's house
taking her photographic albums and
putting them on a bonfire
and burning them lost and gone forever
yes you are the [ __ ]
you're a massive [ __ ] quite frankly
she can do better this is am i the
[ __ ] for being pissed at my parents
for taking us to
athens georgia instead of athens greece
[Music]
i'm already enjoying this story i've
always wanted to go to greece
i love greece so much to the point where
i taught myself how to speak greek
both standard and cypriot and i can read
ancient greek
that's why i was so excited and my
parents said
they would take us on a family vacation
to athens i also made it a priority to
go
check out universities in greece as
that's where i want to go
i showed my parents this and they were
like yeah sure
you can do that we don't care we fly to
atlanta
i assumed it was a layover we land and
my parents said we need to get to the
hotel
and we need a rental car weird but
whatever i wasn't paying attention
well we drive for an hour or so and i
fall asleep in the car
and then my parents say hey we're here
wake up sleepyhead and i see a sign
that says welcome to athens georgia
my sister starts laughing her ass off
and my dad starts giggling i asked them
this was a joke
and they said no that we're going on
vacation to athens georgia
to my dad's friend's lake house i have
never been more angry in my entire life
i don't think you're the [ __ ] in this
situation
i think you've obviously got passion for
all things
greek and it was quite a cruel
trick that your family have
conspired together to play on you
which makes them as a collective
bunch of [ __ ] however there is a
codisl to that accusation
because they're also funny [ __ ]
and that it kind of you know once you
get into the funny [ __ ] you mitigate
the negative
of [ __ ] so no i don't think you're an
[ __ ]
however you do have to think why would
your family conspire so deeply against
you
hmm
steal your nerves brave soldier
[Music]
bye